madame le garde des sceaux le 5 mars
dernier un détenu radicaliser de la
prison de condé sur sarthe dans l'orne
qui je le rappelle est l'une des plus
sécurisées de france poignardé deux
agents de l'administration pénitentiaire
au moyen d'un couteau introduit sans
difficulté par sa conjointe au sein de
l'enceinte carcérale
deux jours plus tard madame la ministre
vous nous faisait part dans cet
hémicycle de votre détermination à
renforcer la sécurité dans les prisons
par une série de mesures visant à
assurer un meilleur ordre une meilleure
protection des gardiens
trois mois plus tard le 11 juin dernier
un détenu qualifié de dps détenu
particulièrement signalé avec à son
actif cinq prises d'otages agression
viol et meurtre de son co-détenu
parvient à prendre en otage deux
surveillants pendant la distribution des
repas au moyen d'une arme artisanale
fabriquée sur place
comme le rappelait ma collègue sénatrice
nathalie goulet lors des questions au
gouvernement du 7 mars dernier les
prisons regorge d'armes artisanales
fabriquées par les détenus de téléphones
portables et d'armes introduite à
l'occasion de visites
force est de constater madame namyst que
le malgré votre détermination le
problème des armes et des portables à
l'intérieur des prisons n'a toujours pas
été résolu j'entends déjà votre réponse
qui interdit aux gardiens de procéder à
des fouilles systématiques et en toute
circonstance des détenus des visiteurs
j'entends déjà que vous n'ayez pas la
possibilité de donner au gardien les
moyens d'exercer des mesures qui leur
permettent de sanctionner détenus
injurieux ou violent sans crainte qu'ils
soient reconnus coupables est ce parce
que vous ne craignez de ne pas vous
oublier aux dictats des droits de
l'homme plutôt que nous soucier à ne pas
trop brusquer nos détenus ne pensez vous
pas qu'il est de notre devoir de
protéger nos gardiens les seules mesures
que vous proposez sont de les équiper de
gillet par l'âme de protège cou ou de
caméra embarquée quand allez vous
attaquer aux causes plutôt que d'essayer
tant bien que mal de parer aux effets
ainsi madame la ministre ma question
sera la suivante pour éviter que cela ne
se reproduise une fois de plus et pour
mettre fin aux innombrables agressions
quotidiennes de nos gardiens
quelles mesures prendre et vous enfin
pour garantir le retour de l'autorité de
l'état dans nos prisons et assurer la
sécurité de ceux qui chaque jour se
dévoue à servian
autre pays merci pour vous répondre la
parole et à madère mais si bête
ndiaye secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre porte parole du
gouvernement
madame la présidente mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je vous prie
d'abord d'excuser l'absence de madame la
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
nicole belloubet qui réunit actuellement
est justement l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde pénitentiaire au cours d'un
séminaire qui a lieu en ce moment même
vous l'avez rappelé les prisons
françaises ont connu et en particulier
celle de condé sur sarthe ont connu des
événements dramatiques des événements
malheureux qui ont impliqué des détenus
vous l'avez rappelé dans votre
intervention
la garde des sceaux dans les deux cas a
diligenté des inspections afin de
déterminer les conditions dans
lesquelles ces événements avaient pu
avoir lieu et elle a pris dans la foulée
de ces événements une série
d'engagements d'abord des effectifs
supplémentaires au delà de
l'organigramme de référence ont été
affectés à condé sur ça le taux
d'occupation de cet établissement que
vous connaissez dans sa particularité
puisqu'il s'agit d'une prison de haute
sécurité avoisine les 60 % de sa
capacité
les équipements qui avait été promis par
la garde des sceaux ont été livrés y
compris la dotation dégradée en bombe
aérosol incapacitantes la création d'ici
la fin de l'année de 10 de 10 unités
pour détenus violents dont deux ont déjà
ouvert leurs portes
soyez assurés évidemment monsieur le
sénateur de notre engagement total de
celui du gouvernement et en particulier
de celui de la garde des sceaux pour
assurer la sécurité des établissements
pénitentiaires je vous remercie